In, in specifying the signature we have given explicit names to
the variables Y and X. And we do this because we'd like to be able to refer to
them in the pre and post conditions by, by some, some name.
Clearly this is simple, similar to what you would do in,
in writing a stub in a programming language like Java. Where you can give
whatever names you'd like to the arguments as long as you consistently use them.
The other thing to note about this is that, we could apply our SORT program
to things other than integers if they ha, satisfy one particular condition,
which is that the basic elements have to be suitable as
arguments to some kind of ordering operation. So greater than, less than,
and so on, are ordering operations. So we can sort ints, we can sort reals,
we can sort, strings and lexical graphic order if that's what we needed to do.